what's worse than devoting your energy
to mastering the impossible or spending
countless hours of your precious time
completing an epic trilogy only to have
the conclusions slap you in your digital
face
not much all right keep the change of
venue button now no you're in texted
here are some of the most insulting
endings in the history of video games
mourning massive spoilers ahead ghosts
and goblins this 1985 side-scrolling
classic is probably the first video game
with a truly insulting ending which
really stings since the game is pretty
solid
aside from it's absurd difficulty your
eyes aren't deceiving you that Knight is
fighting monsters in his undies hits
make you lose your armor until you're
basically questing in the buff developed
by Capcom for our caves but released on
several home consoles ghosts and goblins
rewards players who beat it with the
following text this room is an illusion
and a trap devised by Satan go ahead
dauntlessly make rapid progress yep
that's progress with one s and we're off
the last ask or say if seeing a
misspelled message in return for your
tireless efforts isn't insulting enough
players are then tasked with playing the
game again but this time at an even
harder difficulty why so you can see the
true ending what is the true ending you
asked surely it must be worth the brutal
controller breaking second playthrough
right well you be the judge
congratulation this story is happy end
is the sloppily translated message are
greeted with followed by being the wise
and courageous knight that you are you
feel strong swelling in your body
yes that's familiar feeling strong what
is the great task now required of such a
valiant soldier return to starting point
challenge again this game is a trap
devised by Satan fable to this 2008
open-world RPG sequel is considered by
many to have one of the worst endings to
any video game in history
where to even start first in a lengthy
epic role-playing game one would at
least expect a halfway decent final
confrontation right sure not every video
game can have the best ending ever
but gamers like a little challenge so
what challenge does lionhead studios
present players of fable 2 in the games
at the conclusion press a button any
button just press a button and the
villain dies in fact even if you don't
press a button he dies you literally
don't have to do anything to defeat the
final boss epic to add insult to injury
fable to a game all about choices gives
you a measly 3 final game ending choices
all of which you're relatively
inconsequential and none of which make
much sense in virtually every way fable
2 sets the standard for how not to end
an otherwise fantastic RPG of course
that was the standard until Mass Effect
3 not everyone was insulted by Bioware
is ending to this epic trilogy but those
people weren't paying attention the
result of dozens if not hundreds of
hours exploring fighting
relationship-building planet mining
decision making and cringy romance the
ending to 2012's Mass Effect 3 presents
players with essentially three decisions
control destroy or synthesize all things
considered it's a bit like choosing your
favorite color red green or blue
in other words boring what is your
favorite cut up blue fight ah hello oh
thank you
look that's more or less the only thing
that changes in each ending sequence not
even the most hardcore of Mass Effect
fans could justify this ending as being
anything less than offensive in a game
that's all about choice agency and the
practical effects of your choices every
single player experience almost the
exact same ending the reaction was so
negative
Bioware even released a rewritten and
free dlc ending to try to make up for it
Borderlands gearbox software's
role-playing shooter is no stranger to
silliness however the game's
over-the-top nature simply can't justify
this of
noxious ly offensive ending after 25 to
30 hours of frantic first-person
shooting and role-playing or 60 hours if
you're a completionist Borderlands
rewards players quest for the vault with
a not so pleasant surprise as we've
already learned during gameplay the
vault can only be opened every 200 years
and by the time we've finished
dispatching the destroyer a monstrous
guardian of the prize location the vault
gets filled for another 200 years
needless to say this ending didn't sit
too well with fans nothing like playing
an entire game searching for pieces of a
key to open a legendary vault only to
have said vault shut in your face for
another three lifetimes at least
claptrap is turned into an
interplanetary Ninja Assassin but that's
still just the insulting icing on the
disappointment cake no man's sky this
2016 open galaxy indie sensation has
proven to be one of the most
disappointing games in recent memory if
not of all time however the game might
have had a shred of redeeming quality if
when players arrives at the center of
the galaxy there is a surprise that made
the entire lonely monotonous journey
worth it not only is there no surprise
at the center of the universe there's
literally nothing at the center of the
universe
nothing nothing absolutely nothing to
those gamers lucky enough to have
skipped this ultimately unremarkable
game it's like this just imagine putting
yourself two hours upon hours of almost
mindless drudgery until the faithful
moment arrives and you can finally click
on the center of the universe with the
teeny tiny infinitesimal hopes that
somehow someway it might all be worth it
then then you just watch the map zoom
for several minutes before beginning the
new game not quite you keep all of your
stuff but the ship is broken and you're
in a new universe continuing your
journey with all knowledge and
experience caps
it just breaks your stuff and spit you
out that's it what could possibly be a
worse ending to such an incredibly
disappointing game than asking players
to do it all again you got to give hello
games credit for one thing it
successfully managed to insult just
about
everyone who played this massively
overhyped project stupid y'all bad halo
2 who can forget popping this 2004 xbox
classic into that hulking black beast of
a video game console and drifting away
into beautiful first-person space
shooting bliss
yes those are the good times until the
abrupt and totally insulting cliffhanger
posing as legitimate ending they this
all stare at the screen dumbfounded and
asked although it was apparently not the
ending the creator's wanted to make
players were left with an incredibly
unsatisfying taste in their mouths when
legendary spaceman Master Chief secretly
aboard the space ship called the truth
says this am i telling me what you're
doing on that ship sir finishing this
fight but then he doesn't finish
anything the game cuts to black in music
plays roll credits have fun waiting for
the sequel should be two or three years
tops anyone who looks back fondly if
this cliffhanger as an epic moment in
gaming history is either living a denial
or a victim of revisionist history the
game may have been awesome but the
ending was awful Batman Arkham Asylum
after the amazing gameplay experience of
the first installment in the Arkham
series of Batman games players couldn't
wait for the epic finale Rocksteady
Studios concocted unfortunately the
ending to this 2009 title is weak to put
it mildly The Joker himself is anything
but weak as he injects himself with
Titan a super steroid that makes him
massively muscular and then we get a
super strong Joker because that's what
fans have always been clamoring for the
Joker Plus muscles right yeah yeah now
the ending that comes from this fight is
a serious letdown a steroid inflated
Joker reeks of a lack of creativity and
the whole game culminates on a
forgettable boss battle for a villain
who's always played mind games with the
Caped Crusader using brute strength
simply doesn't sit well the game fails
at doing anything even remotely
interesting with the idea it's just a
standard boss fight and then it's over
although the game itself is objectively
very very good even the most optimistic
of Batman fans can't help that admit
that the ending is pretty lame Final
Fantasy 10
unsatisfied confused bored underwhelmed
these are not feelings you want to
experience after devoting between 80 and
200 hours to a videogame
yes that's what many players were left
feeling after watching what passes for
an ending in 2001 Final Fantasy 10 with
the villainous sin defeated fetus and
Yuna can finally let the good times roll
get married and have some babies right
it's party time for the Summoner and
crew surely the wait you see this a
ghost for a dream heat isn't real what
exactly is happening even by Final
Fantasy standards this ending is more
than a bit convoluted and a whole lot of
lame so lame in fact that a sequel was
required to even get close to justifying
this insulting anticlimactic trash
ending Star Wars Knights of the Old
Republic to the Sith Lords nothing reeks
of rushed ending quite like a few
minutes of dreadfully boring dialogue
you desperately wish you could
fast-forward through all with a somewhat
secondary character about hypothetical
scenarios which fail to actually detail
the fates of characters you've already
invested dozens of hours into sadly this
is what players of the otherwise
excellent 2004 sequel er left with
Knights of the Old Republic to is an
all-around terrific Star Wars
role-playing game blending a great
storyline with solid combat into an
engaging experience the ending however
is anything but engaging it's boring and
loaded with baloney
then when you think about it it is a
prequel series and we all know how those
Star Wars prequels tend to go rampage it
may not have had the worst ending of its
generation because strong but the ending
to this 1986 arcade classic still hits
you right where it hurts
maybe your sad childhood memory here
goes something like this you stayed up
all night with your best friend
determined to beat the NES bored of
rampage perhaps it all started like this
whoa nice graphics I'd like to get my
hands on that game you mean you haven't
played it yet for a game called rampage
starring giant monsters it's actually
kind of dull even when competing
cooperatively with a friend but you
wouldn't turn it off until you
discovered what was at the end of this
nationwide disaster the ending would
justify the experience
right it has to finally you get back to
California level every building dodge
all sorts of military-grade projectiles
and wait anxiously for your reward and
then congratulations that's it
Thank You rampage for ruining at least
five hours of America's childhood stop
bad yeah
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]